yeah this is like this is like a car
crash
oh wow
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by ed helms he's an
actor and comedian whose credits include
some of the all-time most successful
comedy franchises including the office
daily show and the hangover trilogy his
latest project though is true story with
ed and randall an original comedy series
streaming exclusively on peacock ed
helms welcome to the show thank you so
much for having me before we get started
how would you gauge your level of
comfort around spicy food um
in my teens and twenties i i took pride
in really going for the hot stuff my
brother called me asbestos tongue wow
because i could i would always order the
hottest version of whatever we were
eating
i haven't done that in a long time
and i'm i'm
i'm nervous like i'm i'm really nervous
[Music]
good
i mean it's the classic right right
[Music]
piece of cake
i mean
quite yummy
[Music]
so your new show true story with edin
randall is a hybrid scripted unscripted
series where regular people tell you and
randall park their craziest personal
anecdotes which are then brought to life
through dramatic reenactments how much
of a good story would you say is and
what actually happened and then how much
of a good story is and how the story
gets told
well that's a great question
it it it's
it's going gonna come down to the
balance between the two because
something incredibly mundane can be so
funny if it's told really well
i remember louis black back when i was
on the daily show we would be meeting up
at a taping somewhere like a remote
somewhere
and he would just start talking about
his trip to the location
and about his interaction with the the
cab driver that was crazy and then
someone spilled coffee on to the dumbest
sort of story but he was so funny and he
could just kill us with these these
simple stories
then if you have a really like a story
that's inherently crazy
then it actually doesn't need a whole
lot of top spin
where we got really lucky on this show
is that the stories themselves are
absolutely insane and the people that we
got on the show are amazing they're just
incredibly warm
and hilarious and vulnerable people like
they really open up to tell us these
stories it's it's really cool
[Music]
hey i'm getting that garlic
um that's number two
right holy [ __ ] all right
i mean i like it i'm still happy
i'm not angry yet
i'm gonna take another bite there you go
because it is yummy
so one of my favorite parts about your
conversation on pete holmes's podcast is
when that you recognize that the comedy
club in crashing is actually a replica
of the boston uh since shuddered comedy
institution where you began your career
thinking back on those days when you
were hosting the monday night new talent
showcase what about that time in your
career do you miss the most and then
what's a harsh reality about making a
career in comedy that you had to learn
the hard way
great questions um
i think what i miss most about that time
was
it's sort of hard to articulate but
there's this feeling
when you're in the comedy clubs as a as
when you're really starting out and
you're young and there's nowhere to go
but up
you know you're at the bottom rung and
it just feels like anything's possible
your dreams are still
like tangible and
after you're in it for about a year or
so and it's down to like a pretty core
crew of really committed comedians you
really feel a part of something like a
part of a comedy freshman class if you
will and then you had upperclassmen that
that were like slightly more established
and then you had like you know the
seniors that were out there to like
doing big tours and stuff
um i don't know i felt part of something
it was a special special time
calabria very sophisticated sauce
[Music]
yeah i like it
is it true that the bathtub scene and
jeff who lives at home came about with
the duplass brothers basically just
pointing cameras at you and jason siegel
and then just letting you riff in a
40-minute long uninterrupted improv
session
yes um
but actually
uh
that was the whole movie the entire
movie was improvised so
i remember getting the script and being
like oh this script is so great i can't
wait to do this this will be so fun and
then mark and jay were like yeah but
we're not doing any of those lines
you're not gonna say any of it what yeah
we're gonna improvise the whole thing
you and jason are just gonna like
this was improvisation in the service of
like making the dialogue sound as real
and visceral as possible
and that was really a fun challenge i'm
super proud of that movie i'm glad you
brought it up because it doesn't come up
very often
and
and it was a great great project
is it true that there were no special
effects involved in the missing tooth
and the hangover because you actually
just never had an adult incisor grow in
yes that is true
uh some of these sauces are talking back
but um
it was it was in the script
and
so
right away once we got into
pre-production todd the director
was like how are we gonna do this or
what are you comfortable with and i said
uh well let's i don't know we'll talk to
the visual effects guys and they said
okay we'll try blacking it out so we did
a little screen test with just like you
know like halloween pirate costume style
like just some black on the tooth which
actually looks good in person but on
camera it looked terrible but i was like
i
i wasn't gonna say anything but this
tooth is actually fake in my mouth and
uh
and i
i can ask my dentist if we could take it
out i mean it's been a permanent implant
since i was a teenager
i went to my dentist
and he said oh yeah no problem
we can just take the crown off
and like put a little little thing in
there to keep your gum healthy
and i had to go back and shoot the
office at the same time and he so he
made me a retainer with a fake tooth on
it which made me sound drunk because i
was like my tongue couldn't form words
but
we got through it
[Music]
angry goat pepper company
let's do it
i thought like maybe i got a very light
coating
on my wing but upon further
investigation but yeah then it it it it
sort of has a afterburner
right
yeah
still delicious though
so some people watching this may be
surprised to learn that in addition to
being a prolific actor you're also an
experienced banjo player and still
perform alongside your band lonesome
trio which you created in college what's
your defense of the banjo to people who
lump it in with the accordion or the
ukulele or other instruments that don't
get the respect they deserve there's no
defense they're they're exactly right it
there's there's very little redeeming
about a banjo
[Music]
i love the banjo and i love to play it
i consider that a curse
it's obnoxious it's it dominates it's
very hard to play well so most of us
play it kind of badly
i have some little
gene or um clump of brain cells that is
drawn to it and i can't explain it but
uh i would never try to defend a banjo i
never try to convince someone that
banjos are great
either like it or you don't
well i appreciate the education at are
you ready to move on here to the midway
point los calientes rojo that's enough
about bluegrass helms
shut up about the goddamn banjos
let's eat some wings
all right
uh where are we
lois calientes rojo
okay somebody
somebody in the crew just
moaned
because they're scared for me right now
i feel like when you take that first
whoa
where'd you take that bite
and you're like
okay all right it's kind of like when
you sit on a roller coaster and the lap
bar comes down and you're like okay all
right no big deal
you're going up the hill
and then once the sauce kind of like
hits your
hits the whole your whole mouth that's
when the
it expresses itself right you know
all right and we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
graham where we do a deep dive on our
guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so we'll
pull the picture over here on the
monitor and then you just tell us the
bigger story great
can you give us one highlight and one
low light from competing in the malibu
triathlon
that's hilarious the low light
uh of the malibu triathlon for me
was that i was entered in the celebrity
heat and what that means is that
you know that the heats of the triathlon
are go from fastest to slowest so the
first heat is actually the professional
triathletes
and then they get slower from then out
but they stick the celebrity heat second
okay so the celebrities doesn't matter
how fast or slow you are as a celebrity
you're in the second heat
and i'm a really good swimmer so i
actually
did pretty well in the swim but then for
the bike and the run portions the entire
rest of the time i was just getting past
the whole time and
really humiliated everyone was like
seriously helms you can't even keep up
at this point like
but i just was uh i was doing my own
thing moving at my own pace
this next one is the queen majesty coco
ghost okay oh chocolate
it's yummy
it's it's yummy and it's hot
but it's not kicking my ass yet
this one isn't
oh that's a it's such a that's a rather
poetic segue into this question you know
sometimes when guests come onto the hot
one set and they're they're really
confident or think that it won't be a
big deal there's a degree to which i sit
here knowing that they don't realize
that the game is more or less been
rigged to ensure that they fall into a
trap at some point and i'm wondering if
you think there's a connection that
could be made between that and doing
daily show field pieces like to what
degree are you guys playing 3d chess
where even if you go in there and who
you're talking to knows what you're
there to do maybe it's just still
impossible to stop
so you're telling me that
i'm gonna die that's what you're saying
you're telling me that i'm i have a i
now have a false sense of security the
last chapter has not been written yet um
no actually
um it really felt like you were
you were churning a lot of gears to draw
that metaphor but
it's good it's a good one because
shooting a daily show field piece it was
always surprising to me first of all
that certain people were just willing to
talk to us
the other thing that surprised me was
that every time
someone thought that they
knew the show really well and that they
could sort of like outsmart
us
in the interviews
kind of like me like i'm like hey i can
handle some hot sauce
that's they would fall the hardest
because they just they really don't have
any idea like how we do it like what our
techniques are in the interview
and especially in in the edit like what
we're able to do and that and it's like
the more hubris the harder they fall
that's what i've found too sometimes i
make the analogy it's like a
professional wrestler you know when you
start showboating that's when somebody
smashes a chair over the back here sure
you know yeah
well speaking of
are you ready to move on to the next
wing this is 13 angry scorpions jekyll
and hyde oh wow i mean
couldn't it be either or
like 13 angry scorpions feels like
enough of a name
but you have to also be jekyll and hyde
all right
i mean if it's
if it's dr jekyll we're fine
this one's hide this this was hot this
way this is uh mr hyde all right here we
go oh and this has got a lot on it it's
shiny oh yeah this one's shiny
[Music]
i feel like this is like 20 or 30
scorpions
i don't know if they told you but i have
to go do another interview after this i
can tell because of like where the time
slots are you know what i mean like the
one o'clock start i'm like oh well they
probably have more to go after this i'm
gonna be a disaster
or no i think it'll be better it'll be
better as a result you're right you're
right we're gonna provide the rocket
fuel for the rest of your press day yeah
that's that's got a lot of
that's got a lot of kick
so i've heard you describe the process
of creating the andy bernard character
as one of the most thrilling creative
endeavors of your life was there a
particular andy bernardism or piece of
backstory that helped you crack the code
on that character early on
i'm i love that character so much and
i'm so proud of
that the work
on that show
um
but uh
we might need to call a medic just
saying if there's like a mouth medic
like somebody who's specific
no dom just hover over the button
like i feel like maybe a like i could
sit in front of a fire hose and just
that that would feel good right now
um
the most exciting part about the
creation of that character was the tit
for tat between performing and the
writer's writing so they would endow
andy with something really funny and
then i would put some top spin on it
when i was
improvising during a take or something
they would see that like that and add
more to that and so it really was this
feedback loop
and uh in that first season we just
he became a very rich and complex
nuanced character very quickly because
we were just having so much fun kind of
psychoanalyzing this guy
that's how the eight episode deal turns
into six seasons that's right yeah
all right
ed how we doing how we doing
we're good i mean my nose is sprinting
but let's do this
[Music]
beyond insanity and it actually has a
biohazard symbol on the label
here we go
oh yeah
oh wow
oh
that's different
that's
there's nothing redeeming about that
it's not it doesn't taste wow
wow
so i always think it's funny when things
like
boiled peanuts from the methodist men of
inglewood church in north carolina
become coveted items and the gift guides
of fancy food magazines
oh my god
[Music]
as an atlanta raised polite southern boy
yourself what role did roadside boiled
peanut stands play in your life are you
seriously trying to do this interview
still
like
this has turned into
like a uh
[Applause]
yeah this is like this is like a car
crash
oh wow
that is so brutal
wow
roadside boiled peanut stands was very
much a part of like southern
back road or highway culture
and uh my dad loved boiled peanuts
he's from alabama and
i just grew up
eating boiled peanuts out of paper bags
a lot on road trips and i loved it and i
missed it and
there's not much more to that story are
you happy now
for the uninitiated what is a pimento
cheese sandwich then what distinguishes
a good one
um
okay
a pimento cheese sandwich
i mean it's amazing how good you are
just staying on track so i'm just gonna
try i'm going to rise
to your level i'm going to try to answer
these questions connect waveforms even
though
i'm going to need a defibrillator
very soon
dom get that medic
there is no bad pimento cheese i've had
the gamut like my elementary school
would give pimento cheese sandwiches on
field trips
and it was like wonder bread with like
the crappiest ingredients delicious i
loved it
and then my mom would make like this
exquisite recipe with like all kinds of
spices and stuff
also amazing
um
i'm throbbing my face is the front of my
face is throbbing
this is doing permanent damage
like this is doing
damage to my
mouth and
it's doing neurologic damage like i
can't think straight i'm unable to like
carry on a clear conversation with you
equally ruling i think things are coming
out of my mouth i can barely feel it
oh man
this is also bringing out like the inner
masochist in me like i'm having fun like
i do want to keep going
oh i should have taken a pepsi before
this oh yeah
um
okay extra mean green pucker butt great
name
[Music]
well i couldn't tell you what it tastes
like or what it feels like because it's
completely not that's the blessing
that's the blessing of the bomb that's
the blessing of the bomb
but uh but just having something in my
mouth is a little bit soothing so i'm
gonna take another bite
wow putting on a show
how would you describe your complicated
relationship with acapella music you
once told new york magazine that it's
the most paradoxical art form there is
it is right
when people are performing acapella
music there's there's like even even if
they're the most benevolent wonderful
kind human beings
it just comes across as kind of like
smug and self-indulgent i don't know why
that is
it's a weird thing
that said
it is the most fun thing to do like if
you're in a good a cappella group which
i was in college shout out to oberlin
oberlin overtones
we were so tight it was so fun like it
just is really fun to do
um so yeah it's a weird
i think anyone who's into acapella music
kind of understands that
that uh
paradox
[Music]
all right ed yeah are we shaking it up
[Music]
you don't have to if you don't want to
of course i'm not going to buck a
tradition are you kidding me
[Music]
seriously like two drop that was like
four drops
and and and you
were like just looking out for the rest
of it okay good thank you
i'm gonna trust you
cheers ed
what a ride hey yeah this is super fun
and cool and
harmful
here we go
again
the lap belt's coming down i don't know
what ride i'm in for you yet
this one it
billows a little bit it grows a little
bit but don't worry because while you
enjoy that wing i have a nice long a
nice long wind up for you because at
long last we can call for the check here
on our bizarre dinner date with the
wings of death and if we've learned
anything along the way add your man of
many talents from stand-up comedy to
acting to playing the banjo but i know
that it all began the roots of it all
were in commercial narration
people might be surprised to know how
prolific you were as a voice over actor
but have you ever done an ad read with a
billion scovilles coursing through your
body today just maybe if you'll
humor me
i have some ad copy for you and i'm
hoping that we can close out the show
today with some throwback ed helms
commercial narration
yeah well you did your research by the
way you've asked some very like uh some
sort of deep cut questions here i'm very
impressed
and yeah not a lot of people know i used
to do voiceover for commercial but
but i did and i will do it for this
if you or a loved one has been diagnosed
with mesothelioma you you may be
entitled to financial compensation
mesothelioma is a rare cancer link to
asbestos exposure exposure to asbestos
in shipyards mills heating construction
or the automotive industries may put you
at risk
call that 800 number right now wait a
minute look at you ed helms did i just
endorse something at some like ambulance
chaser law firm or something what just
happened taking on the wings of death
and living to tell the tale and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life ah
well thank you very very much this was
super fun and uh
we but yeah i have a new show coming out
on peacock it's called
true story with ed and randall randall
park and i sit down with real people and
we hear real true stories from their
lives
it is incredibly
funny it is incredibly warm hearted and
uh poignant it's just a fabulous show
and i'm incredibly proud of it
and uh so proud that i would even drink
all this hot sauce just so that i get 10
seconds to talk about it well lucky for
us
[Applause]
cheers
all right thanks so much yeah cheers
cheers thank you super fun
and you did it you did it thanks for
doing so much research you guys really
like
you got into some like obscure stuff i
appreciate it well you know if we're
going to have you eat these wings we got
to meet you make it worth it make it
worthwhile absolutely and we're going to
package up those bosses
don't bother
hey what's going on hot ones fans sean
evans just want to say thank you so much
for watching today's episode and if
while you were watching you thought to
yourself you know what i would love to
try that at home well guess what now you
can because the season 17 hot ones hot
sauce box is now available heatness.com
heatness.com heatness.com to get your
hands on the sauces look at how it looks
on the inside so pretty
well oh we got boom mic problems the box
is so big and you know what always with
the cautionary tale
be careful around the eyes hot ones
season 17 the full sauce lineup now
available
at heatness.com
[Music]